Today we examine a case that deals with contracts in the modern world of
technology and Internet contract.
Many of you use web based services such as Google,
Facebook,
or apps on your phone,
uh,
like Uber or seamless.
Do you remember the last time you read through the terms and conditions of any
of those service contracts?
Have you wondered why some surfaces require you to separately click a button to
accept the terms and conditions whereas others do not.
These issues are raised in sprec versus Netscape.
A 2002 case that was heard by the second circuit.
The decision was authored by judge,
uh,
Sotomayor,
who as you know,
is now a supreme court justice.
Before we turn to the case,
let's take a moment to learn a few key concepts.
Click wrap refers to an electronic agreement in which are user indicates
agreement to terms by clicking on our radio button,
checking a box or the like.
Usually as a condition of using a device or a piece of software.
Browse wrap refers to terms of use,
often found via link or a website's main page that purport to bind to user
solely by virtue of his or her continued use of the site.
These terms come from uh,
the use of quote shrink wrap contracts which were frequently litigated in the
1990s.
Shrink wrap contracts were commonly used in boxed software packages which
contained a notice that by on the outside of the box that by tearing open the
shrink wrap the user was assenting to the software terms and closed with it.
In this Brecht case,
the plaintiff Apelle Lee's downloaded defendant netscapes smart download
program.
This was a program which facilitated transmission of files online.
Underneath the download button in a nonobvious position was a link to the terms
associated with the download and use of the smart download.
A software and arbitration clause was included among those terms.
The smart download program allowed Netscape to record any subsequent downloads
obtained by smart download users.
Plaintiff's claim that this feature violated federal privacy laws.
Netscape moved to compel arbitration in accordance with the terms associated
with the smart download,
uh,
terms and conditions as well as Netscape,
communicator and associated program.
The plaintiff argued that arbitration would not be appropriate because they
hadn't agreed to it.
In other words,
argued that the arbitration clause hidden underneath the download button was not
enforceable.
The District Court denied the defendant's motion to compel arbitration.
The instinct court affirmed the district court's ruling.
The main issue in the case as you can already tell is whether the plaintiffs are
bound by the terms of a download program,
if they could have reasonably downloaded the program without becoming aware of
the existence of the terms.
In other words,
the main issue is whether the kind of browse wrap agreements at east,
uh,
in this case are enforceable.
The second circuit's sided with the plaintiffs.
They ruled that an offeree must receive clear notice of a contracts associated
terms if a download is to constitute acceptance of those terms.
A contract requires mutual assent because plaintiffs did not assent to the
contractual terms and could not be expected to be aware of the terms existence.
They are not bound by the arbitration clause.
So what law did the court apply to this transaction where the subject matter is
a license of intangible software?
The court's answer here,
it's the common law when pressed.
Some courts might apply the UCC by analogy to supplement the common law.
However,
remember the,
that the UCC article two only applies to the sale of goods.
Something else that might apply is the uniform computer information transactions
act you see to the model act was designed to govern computer information
transactions.
Section one oh three,
a of that act,
uh,
has defined computer information and information in electronic form which is
obtained from or through the use of a computer or which is in a form capable of
being processed by a computer.
Section one 12 a would have dealt with click wrap and browse wrap stating that a
person manifests dissent if she intentionally authenticates the term or engages
in behavior that is likely to be perceived as manifesting descent.
But only two states,
Virginia and Maryland have enacted.
You see them.
And the project has been abandoned by the national conference of Commissioners
after several states enacted legislation prohibiting,
you see there from regulating transaction within their borders.
The American Law Institute adopted principles of the law of software contracts
in 2009 but it remains to be seen how influential these principles will have a
how much impact they'll have on judicial opinions.
However,
this doesn't mean that browse wrap agreements are never okay.
The court held that browse wrap agreements may be enforced if the browsing user
a sense to it.
This is going to be done on a case by case basis and there are no bright line
rules,
but the key is that a given agreement must be sufficiently conspicuous.
What are some ways to make a browse wrap agreement highly visible?
Well,
some suggests that the icon for the terms of the user agreement can be placed in
the upper left hand quadrant of the homepage because Internet pages open from
the upper left hand quadrant.
This guarantees that the user will be able to see the icon.
Think back to the last time you used Google,
not g-mail or Google chat or some other Google service,
but Google the search engine.
Did you remember accepting the terms and conditions for Google search?
Google search terms and conditions are on the bottom right hand corner of its
page and as you can guess,
it's usually a browse wrap because you don't have to click on any button to
accept it.
Usage of the service means you're agreeing to the conditions.
Let's turn back to the click wrap agreements for a second.
There is a little question that click rack agreements there.
There's little question that clicker agreements are presumptively enforceable.
Courts have held that a click is usually enough to satisfy agreement to an
electronic transaction,
but both cognitive theory and empirical studies demonstrate that this might not
be such a good thing.
Professor Robert Hilleman and Jeffrey were Klonsky argue that while an
individual's opportunity to protect herself against one sided standard form
contracts is are arguably greater when contracting by computer.
Then when contracting through written forms,
the cognitive perspective that consumers tend to adopt with respect to
contractual risks makes it unlikely that many will take advantage of these new
electronic tools.
In short,
almost no one reads the terms of the click wrap license before assenting to the
program.
In a study of 47,000 households over a one month period,
the readership of end user license agreements is,
was found to be on the order of 0.12 w uh,
1%.
Maybe this explains how the British software retail our game station was able to
successfully add an immortal soul clause to its end user license agreement,
which stated that the user would give up his or her immortal soul at the
seller's request.
Making matters worse,
consumers sometimes demonstrate something that might be called term optimism.
The consumer sometimes believes that the contractual terms are more favorable to
them than they actually are.
For instance,
in a survey of consumers,
uh,
concerning insurance,
the consumers believed they had more coverage from different types of harm than
the insurance actually offered.
So the consumer attributes more utility to the insurance contract and the
contract actually generates for her.
Some websites require users to actually click through and even scroll through to
the bottom of the terms before they're able to agree to accept the offer.
A few websites even required the term box to be open for a certain amount of
time before the offer becomes acceptable,
uh,
to assure that the consumer had enough time to actually read the terms.
But the vast majority of websites,
uh,
make it so that the consumer offer re,
doesn't have to read.
Uh,
and it's,
and it's possible of course,
if the consumer offerings don't want the hassle of these extra clicks are these
extra precautionary devices.
They prefer a bug may not approach to contract formation,
even if it leads to the problem of term optimism.
Now,
section two,
11 of the restatement of contracts,
um,
which is sometimes referred to as the know thy customer provision might provide
a little bit of consumer protection against this,
uh,
term optimism section two 11 states.
If the other party has reason to believe that the other party manifesting such a
scent would not do so.
If he knew that the writing contained this term,
then that term is not a binding part of the agreement.
A comment to the section notes that customers do not in fact ordinarily
understand or even read the standard terms.
They trust the good faith of the party using the form.
Although customers tick typically,
uh,
adhere to standardize agreements,
it doesn't make sense to bind them to unknown terms which are beyond the range
of reasonable expectations.
For instance,
this comment says a debtor who delivers a check to his creditor with the amount
of blank does not authorize an infinite figure.
Uh,
we're not giving the sellers blank checks when we click through on these
contracts.
Professor Alan Schwartz and I have proposed another solution in an article which
we published in the Stanford Law Review.
We suggested that sellers should be required to disclose a standardized warning
box containing unexpected unfavorable terms.
And this is actually an example of such a box as applied to Facebook,
but we also suggested that representative consumers should be empowered to waive
the provision of some of these terms.
If it turns out that a majority of consumers would prefer not to be warned,
then the seller would be able to forego a providing this warning box of
unexpected.
We suggested that this would together create a kind of form democratization
where customers would have the power to both be warned about unexpected terms
and the power to waive those terms.
If representative consumers would prefer not to be bugged by them.
If the representative consumers find these to be unhelpful,
then they wouldn't have to see them.
In our paper,
we actually tested 25 core questions about Facebook terms concerning privacy,
a statement of rights and responsibility.
And we were trying to see which terms are the terms that people would expect in
which terms are unexpected and unfavorable.
We found five unexpected unfavorable terms and this slide shows you the two that
were most unexpected and unfavorable.
And we'll provide the kind of examples that we were trying to,
uh,
disclose to consumers.
So,
uh,
today we have examined click wrap and browse wrap contracts.
We learned that while click wrap,
uh,
agreements are usually enforceable.
Browse wrap agreements are not enforceable unless they are sufficiently visible.
However,
consumers rarely read a click wrap terms or the terms in a browser rack a
agreement.
Either a better option might be to ensure that sellers disclose terms that are
unexpected and unfavorable.